- [Drew] In honor of Nora from Queens
and Awkwafina being from Queens,
I thought that maybe we could play
a little trivia game to test how much
you really know about your hometown.
You game?
- Yeah.
- [Drew] Okay.
- I re- I really hope I know
about my hometown, yeah.
- It's a little game we're
calling Queen of Queens.
(audience cheering)
- [Drew] Now, since I'm not from Queens,
I thought you should play against another
true blue Queens native.
Please welcome the
legendary Fran Drescher.
(audience cheering)
- [Akwafina] Yes!
Yes!
Oh my, oh!
- [Fran] Hi, everyone!
- I can't believe I'm here right now.
- I love both you girls.
I'm so happy to be included
in this Queen of Queens game.
- (squeals) Oh, god!
- I love you so much!
- I'm in like a Queens of Queens sandwich.
- Awkwafina! I should be
your neighbor on the show!
- Yes, I'm sending the offer right now.
The offer's coming.
(audience laughing and cheering)
- Maybe it's the love
connection that we're playing.
- Awkwafina from Queens.
I mean, you're carrying the torch girl.
And I'm really, really thrilled.
- [Akwafina] Oh, thank you.
Where- where do- can we break away from-
Where in Queens are you?
- Flushing!
- You're from Flushing?
That's crazy.
Did you go to, did you go to Lum's?
- Of course! That's where
my sister's sweet 16 was.
- What?
No way!
(applause)
That's my family's restaurant.
- Really?
Oh, when I come to Queens, we should go.
- Yes. Yes.
- By the way,
you know, Fran, I was reading
something that you said once.
Is it true that like one
television executive said to you,
like your voice?
I don't know.
And then another person was
like, it's because of you,
your voice, your personality,
that this is going to work.
- Yes, actually, I mean,
all along the road,
people said that the voice
was going to hold me back.
And it was Peter Jacobson,
my writing producing partner
and my beloved gay ex-husband
(audience laughs)
who said, the voice, the
face, the comic timing.
That's what's going to make you a star
and we're going to lean into it.
We're not going to try and
dilute it or move away from it.
And, and he was right.
You know, I'm really grateful.
But back in the day, when we
had sold the idea for the show,
they actually said,
can the character be
Italian and not Jewish?
- [Drew] Right, and you said no.
- We said no, we couldn't
write it as authentically.
I know how to be Jewish, we
know how to write Jewish.
That's the way we have to go.
And I kind of just, even though
I knew it was my big break,
we said, no, because I don't,
I don't like to have regret.
And I thought, If I go along
with this idiotic suggestion
and it doesn't fly, I'm
going to be kicking myself.
Why did I listen to them?
So, you know, just kind
of make it a Cardinal rule
that I go with my gut and I
try and convince everybody
why I think it's the right idea.
Why did I (indistinct) pleaser.
- Well, I thank you both
for putting out shows
authentic to who you are
and changing the world
to welcome other people
to find that confidence and do the same.
So thank you for that, seriously.
(audience applause)
And so your origin story starts in Queens.
We're going to play a game.
You guys are going to take
turns, answering questions
with multiple choice options
and the person with the
most correct answers
wins the Queen of Queens.
Let's get to it, The first
question goes to Awkwafina.
Awkwafina, what famous magician is buried
in a cemetery in Queens?
Is it A - David Copperfield,
B - William Ellsworth Robinson,
C - Magicians can't always be
put in a box, they can escape.
Or D - Harry Houdini?
- I want to say Houdini,
but I feel like it might
be Copperfield, or C.
Oh God, they're going to come.
The magicians are going come after me.
The magicians are gonna come.
Houdini.
- Okay, well, it's Harry Houdini.
- Oh it's Harry Houdini,
it's Harry Houdini!
(audience applause)
We've got crowns falling from the sky.
Okay, Fran, what neighborhood of Queens
did Cindy Lauper grow up in?
Was it Ozone park - A.
B - Jackson Heights,
C - girls just want to have Flushing?
Or D - Sunny Side?
- I'm going to say Ozone Park.
- You are right!
(audience applause)
- Okay, Awkwafina.
Which one of these people of
note was not born in Queens?
A - Howard Stern,
B - Tony Danza,
C - Lori Loughlin,
or D - Al Roker.
- [Akwafina] Oh-Oh, man.
I almost want to say Howard Stern.
but I don't know.
(laughing)
I don't know.
Can I have a lifeline?
Can I take a lifeline?
Fran what do you think?
What do you think it is?
- I think your first, instincts are right.
I'm going to say Howard Stern.
- Well, you'll both be interested
to know it's B Tony Danza.
He was not born in Queens.
- Oh.
- He was born in Brooklyn.
(laughing)
Okay, Fran's turn.
Which subway line runs through Queens?
A - the 6 train,
B - the D train,
C - the A train,
D - IDK.
- I'm gonna guess the D.
(buzzer noise)
- It is the, A train.
- The A train goes to Queens?
- Apparently.
- It does. It goes.
- All right. This score is tied.
- It's been a while since
I've taken the subway.
(Akwafina laughs)
But I've been stuck in
a train car with fans,
there's no way out you know?
- No.
- Yeah, yeah.
Okay, last question goes to Awkwafina.
What part of Queens did
The Nanny take place in?
A - Astoria,
B - Forest Hills,
C - Flushing,
D - Drescher Island?
- C, Right?
- Yes!
(audience applause)
- I'm the flashy girl from Flushing.
- The flashy girl from
Flushing, the nanny named Fran.
- Well, the accumulative
winner is Awkwafina today,
but you are both Queens.
Two amazing Queens who
have changed the world.
(audience applause)
- Three queens. Three queens.
- Awkwafina and Fran Drescher.
I am so honored to be in your
Queens sandwich right now.
And may we all be able
to come together again,
as soon as possible.
Nora, from Queens
Wednesdays at 10/9 Central
on Comedy Central.
(upbeat music)